it's really nice to see people show up I
thought okay I'm not up against ly Tales
but I am up against lunch and and about
doing cool things with attackers on
Androids so you know I'll have so who's
the pastor and who's the programmer from
Wisconsin um so thank you for for coming
I hope it turn out to be worth your
while and I hope I don't trip over this
tape too much
okay why do programming languages matter
um what the origin of this talk is that
some of us in in Sig plan essentially uh
put together decided we needed a a
meaning and I offered to put together a
talk sort of based around this logo uh
programming language research needs you
so we had our goal was to convince
perspective and new graduate students to
study programming languages rather than
say the internet of things or expert
systems or HCI or deep more networks or
whatever the favor of the day was and
why why are we doing this well
essentially self-interest right we want
the best graduate
students but there's a more sort of
fundamental reason this is the best way
to win a churing
award and we know all our graduate
students want to win a churing award and
if you uh look at the ACM website about
tring Awards you'll see there's this
word cloud and and programming language
shows up you know like a pretty major
topic um and these are the nine
programming language related Award
winners the ACM uh picked out um if you
scan down the list I found it pretty
easy to come up with another 11 that
they'd missed um so in total something
like 20 out of 78 uh cheing Award
winners over the existence of that award
have been related to programming
language so the word cloud should
actually um I didn't not another click
look something like that right right
okay so programming languages have had
are considered to be by at least the
people who give out chewing Awards to be
an important part of of computer
science but why this doesn't really
answer the question right what is it
and James Noble um said something
similar to this is a quote he gave me
when I asked this question to some of
the members of working group 2.
16 um software is the most important
infrastructure for well basically
everything in the modern world uh
software is totally dependent on
programming languages you can't write
software without some kind of
programming language so languages are
the most important infrastructure for
anything and
everything and but you knew that right
that's why you're here that's why you
Pro work in this field or have an
interest in this field because you
realize it has an enormous societal
impact so you didn't come to hear me say
that uh but a more dramatic way of
expressing the same idea um we can say
thank you to
Michelangelo uh here is god with the
power of creation right uh bringing Adam
to life this is from the seeding of the
cine Chapel um programmers are like
Wizards except the magic is real
programming languages are spell
systems this was sea mcdom why all these
quot
here well because other people often say
things better than I
did but I had a conversation at dinner
last night with a fellow academic from
the open University who and I said you
know programming languages I told her my
thesis I'll tell you in a moment and she
said that's all it's all hogwash right
she didn't say that she was much more
polite but she said they're certainly
not the only point of view I've done a
lot of research and talked to lots of
experts and I come up with a different
answer so it's okay if talking to
experts is doing research I've talked to
experts too and this is what they tell
me Arthur C Clark famously said any
sufficent sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic and if we look at some of the
Technologies we routinely carry around
today people from even 50 years ago
would think they were magic this is a
more modern picture of the same idea
right of heri Granger with a spell
system okay so so that was sort of the
fluff part uh the more interesting
reason to me um that programming
language is matter is that programming
languages shape the way we think about
programming at least they shape the way
I think about programming and also a lot
of the people I've interacted with over
my
career and this is not a new idea right
it um you probably know this as a weak
form of a sappia WF hypothesis uh Safir
and War were anthropological linguists
around operating at the beginning of the
20th century um and they had this idea
that one's native language determines
one's perception of the world and the
extreme form like you can't think of
something that you can't express in your
language is is clearly overblown right
we do that all the time that's how
invention
happens but the more um softer form that
says um
the languages shape the way we think
seems to me to be indubitably true based
on my own experience and those people I
talk to uh the picture of vilhelm Von
hbal by the way is because this idea did
not come from sapv it came from uh from
humbal about 100 years earlier so let's
give credit where credit's
due um so a real world example of this a
modern one is um there's an AB original
language from Australia called gooo yth
or something like that it has words for
the cardinal directions North South East
and so forth but it has no words for
left right in front of
behind how does this shape the way
people of that tribe who speak this
language
think so the claim is and this is not
original research from me as you
probably imagine but the claim is that
you have to be constantly aware of which
way you're facing which way is North
which way is
south
and in an out a culture that lives
Outdoors where the sun is usually
shining it's maybe not too
hard but imagine trying to teach someone
to
dance in this
language particularly like a circle
dance where your direction is the mind
boggles right so this is a real example
from anthropology a programming language
example which might might not be more
convincing to you is supposing all you
know is basic and your basic uh basic
actually has oneline functions but
suppose you have a basic doesn't even
have on line functions all we've got is
go sub and procedures without
parameters how are you going to envisage
functional
programming where composition is kind of
the main tool rather
than uh functional composition rather
than sequential composition is the main
tool for for writing a
program I won't say it's not possible
because some people came up with this
idea of functional programming right but
it's certainly not going to be the easy
smooth Groove into which your mind
slides so um Tom batam captured this
idea learning a new language changes the
path of least resistance in your
brain that things that you might not
have thought of first although you might
have thought of eventually now become
second
nature okay
um Alan Peis famously said a language
that doesn't affect the way you think
about programming is not worth
knowing of course he didn't have to earn
his living by writing programs so there
are some reasons you sometimes need to
use a language uh that you might not
otherwise want to
learn um and there's also this
interesting idea that I'm not going to
expand on most of you probably have
heard about it it's called The blab
Paradox and if we get time at the end I
can explain the bra Paradox if you want
but the idea is whatever language you
happen to use and you've been using it
for a while dictates the way you think
about programs so you can't really
appreciate the virtues of other
languages languages that are less
powerful look like they're just too weak
to be useful languages are more powerful
just look
weird uh and this is an idea from Paul
Graham in a a blog post called beating
the
averages um BR Victor famously said a
programming language has has two parts
the programming environment is the part
that's installed on the computer and the
programming language is the part that's
installed in the programmer's head right
BR Victor says a lot of intelligent
stuff right uh this is about uh from a
from an essay on learnable programming
but I I shouldn't digress because uh we
have a time limit there are plenty of
seats up the front if the people
crowding by the back door want to move
down so please
do it always makes me feel good when
there are students in the front row and
they're
awake so my
recommendation is that you should
program in a pure functional language if
you haven't
already you should program with pure
objects so learning small talk because I
had to teach it next quarter uh learning
small changed the way my brain works and
I've never thought about programming in
the same way again
uh I suggest you do program with
communicating processes and CSP
implementations aren't that widely
available Earl Lang is a pretty good
approximation you know about object
oriented programming this is process
oriented programming it's a different
way of
thinking okay do try logic
programming I I hesitate to recommend
programming but there are many now more
modern programming languages uh
colleague of mine works on carry which
is functional logic it still has
unification you can also write functions
um very powerful language and again uh
it really it's like I'm go smacked I
thought that was a problem description
but you're telling me that's actually
the running
program uh so use these languages for a
serious project you know running hello
world in small talk isn't going to teach
you anything um but actually building
something significant yeah it's going to
be work um but you will benefit from it
your brain will thank you
you so the thesis of my
talk um I I is essentially that um for
programmers the languages you know are
major influence on the way that you
think as a
programmer and for language designers
under which category I put myself the
languages you know are major influence
on the languages you
design so I'm not going to try and go
back through the whole history of all
the ing languages that have been
designed and look at their genealogy and
where they're designed their ideas
that's a great research project it's
probably several phds um a great
resource if you're interested in this is
to look at the proceedings of the
various history of programming languages
conferences uh starting in 1978 and the
most recent one
was well it would have been in 20 20 um
and eventually happened virtually in
2021 which was a big disappointment um
but they're great
papers so what am I going to do um I'm
going to look back at my personal
history and the languages that I've had
some input into as a designer right and
there are seven of them I think the
abstract said six but that just goes to
show I can't
count um I'd actually forgotten about
Alo H um so we've got the names of the
languages on this Slide the years um so
1977 is when I started so I guess that's
actually 40 5 years or 46 years so I I
really can't count um UEA was my
undergraduate university university of
East Anglia and vws was my undergraduate
supervisor so this was like my
undergraduate thesis
project uh Brian shearing was a
colleague of Tony hores when I was at
Oxford he was a consultant uh who had
this contract that was great because it
was paying for his lunch but it also uh
gave him some problems which he came to
us uh the Eden system I'll talk about
um it turns out that the customer really
does influence the language or at least
I think it should so let's move ahead
and start with our go H 1977 this is the
punch card era and I'm I'm an
undergraduate and I'm programming for my
undergraduate classes in this language
called Alo 68 which you probably have
heard of it's I think it's got a bad rap
um but um compared to foron 4 which was
a language we used in the first year
this language was wonderful I can tell
you it was great um but this book showed
up in the bookstore this was the days of
book sores and books um structure
programming by Dar dyra and and
there's three sections by each of those
authors uh the dyra section is on uh
structuring code and he introduces the
idea of stepwise refinement which is
very famous dar's uh section is a
essentially introducing the concepts of
obori
programming but it's pretty much
impenetrable at least it was to me there
I think if you already understand the
concepts now you could get something out
of it but not at the time and um H's
section was notes on data structuring
where he was talking about data
structuring rather than code structuring
so um data structures like records and
uh enumeration types and things like
that which I thought was really cool so
what I decided to do um given I knew
that you know a 68 was good and hor data
structures look really good um if I
combine the two things together that
should be a decent project um and of
course that would end up being double
plus
good well any of you have ever tried to
combine two or more good ideas know that
that's not quite how things work out in
practice um but it was you know a good
idea and going through the uh the report
I wrote about it I came across this
sentence um a closing of the gap between
data structures of the program and The
Real World objects they represent this
sounds like a prescription for object
oriented programming right it's what
I've been actually been trying to do for
the next 46 years um so uh maybe there
was some some great insights in
there okay so what did I learn from this
process well the first lesson is that
consolidation is hard than Innovation
mostly i' chosen well the hor data
structures and Alo 68 actually meshed
together fairly well because they're
both inspired by ago 60 which is you
know where we all started from if if we
didn't start from foran there was one
exception uh tagged unions and untagged
unions so Alo 68 had untagged unions and
they collapsed if you unioned integer
and integer for example that was just an
integer uh horse data structures had
essentially what became Pascal variant
records so and so there were tagged
unions and you could inquire which side
of the of the Union are you on it didn't
seem like a good idea to put both of
these in the same language um and
probably tag unions were a better idea
but hour 68 had gone the other way so
the lesson from there is that if you
have a destination in mind be careful
from where you
start and my recommended reading for
this is not my paper on alol H which you
know for an undergraduate project report
isn't bad but it's not really a paper I
love um it's this paper by Charles
Lindsay on history of ago 68 so I've
mentioned hoel conferences this is from
hoppel 2 I read this again recently I'd
forgotten just what a stunningly good
paper it
is so I it's it's well written it's
amusing it gives you some insights into
what goes on on a large committee where
you have a bunch of strong minded people
who disagree how the language actually
got put together he doesn't claim it's
the perfect language but he does explain
why it's the way it is and one of the
things he talks about of course is Alo
68 parameter passing mechanism and he
repeats a version of this old story you
know you going to a small village in
Ireland and you ask a guy by the side of
the road can you tell me how to get to
bad Clary and he says oh oh if you
really wanted to get to bad Clary you
wouldn't start from
here and and that's sort of the story of
parameter passing in Alo 68 they started
from Alo 60 Alo 60 had of course call by
value which is like copy in and it had
call by name which is re-elaborate the
expression each time the formal
parameter is mentioned the expression
actually was T treated like a procedure
this gave rise to a thing called
Jensen's device where you could write an
expression in the procedure call and
because it's reevaluated all values of
an array index actually gives you
different elements of an array people
thought this was great it's a terrible
idea
right yeah I mean it's powerful but can
anyone actually understand what's going
on you know it's the kind of thing you
the nasty professors put on programming
exams but the people who are designing
Alo 68 didn't want to come up with a
language that was less than Alo 60 right
so they had to find a way to incorporate
this idea and that's where the procedure
in corer in 68 comes from which everyone
agrees is also a bad idea so later on it
got a bit better because you had to
actually explicitly write that coercion
essentially write something was could be
recognized as a Lambda expression in the
call the problem with Jensen's device is
it couldn't explicitly be recognized as
a Lambda expression there was no Syntax
for that so be careful from where you
start because it's going to determine
where you end
up okay
um how three R you've never heard of
this language either um 3r in English
stands for Reading Writing
arithmetic and uh this picture on the
right hand side of the screen is
actually the language refa it's like 50
56 pages of a of an A5 booklet typed on
a selectric typewriter controlled by the
CTO module one computer that we had at
Oxford at the time but um
it was a programming language designed
for readability and one of the things we
did for example was let names be made up
of multiple words separated with spaces
not minor signs or underscores but just
spaces and we had uh blocks which are
like procedures and the names of the um
of the blocks I can't really point over
there but um actually have parameters or
rather arguments in the middle of the
name and also parameters when you wrote
wrote The Heading it seemed like just
such an obvious idea I didn't know that
small talk had already done this right
but they had and it just makes things so
much more readable um there are also
these things called blocklets which had
names but no arguments and that was it
there was it was flat there was no
nesting you couldn't have procedures
inside
procedures oddly the language had no
Loops but it did have recursion because
it had
names so that was the where you built
Loops um and the other thing it had was
a mechanism for failure handling we call
tested
invocations so where did this weird
language come from well of course it
came in part from Fortran because that
was the language in which you wrote real
programs um it came from this thing
called the fora program so the story
here is that Brian sharing who I
mentioned earlier had won a contract
from the UK government to produce a
readable and ex executable program that
was going to be part of the contractual
description for all government contracts
involving payment over time okay this is
19 uh late 1970s inflation is running at
12 14 16% every month depending on what
you've built you get paid for what you
built this month I put in Windows last
month I ped concrete inflation adjusted
prices of all of these things very so
there's this very complicated quantity
surveying calculation that has to be
part of the contract so it has to be
readable by a lawyer but it also has to
be executable by a computer so therefore
it had to be written in for train Brian
was smart enough to realize that these
two things were fundamentally
incompatible there was no
way it was bad enough for programmers to
try and read Fortran that lawyers
weren't going to do it so he wrote the
program in a language called
3r and then hand translated it into
Fortran so there's actually a direct
correspondence between these uh
structures um the uh the recursion all
translates into Loops because foran
didn't have recursion um and so on so
the other influences that I brought to
this coming from Oxford were I Ed Eder
D's book a discipline of programming and
his language of guarding commands which
was one of the Hot Topics at the time
and then a a colleague from Toronto Eric
haa had wrote this paper called do
considered odd which essentially is a
critique
of dous calculus which is not to say
dous calculus is bad it's really good
and it was a big step forward but then
once somebody has taken that step you
can look at it and say but those bits
don't really fit so well and the last
influence was os6 which was the
operating system we ran at that time was
actually OS 12f at Oxford on the modular
1 so what came the only thing that came
from os6 is this idea of run versus is
finish and give up so you run a program
as an operating system operating systems
run programs the program could end by
doing one of two things it could finish
the normal case or it could give up
sometimes when you're trying to do
something you find you can't and you
give up right so all through a real
program there are tests of have I given
up yet right because often the system
doesn't give you way of
exiting so the other influence was Tony
who was my supervisor and
professor of a computation at Oxford at
the time and Tony said simplify simplify
simplify until it hurts then simplify
some
more I don't have a citation for that
it's just in my head what he told me to
do the citation you probably familiar
with it this quote from the emperor's
old clothes his chewing award lecture
um which I just let you
read
so doing things simply is difficult and
Tony was actually talking about uh
language design when he wrote that not
about programs but um I think it applies
to programs
too so what was Eric haa uh complaining
about in dius Calculus what's odd about
this do uh if you're not familiar with
D's language of guarded commands um
there's assignments and declarations but
there are two kind of executable control
statements there's the if and the do and
uh the if basically says well any of
those guards before the statement if
it's true execute the corresponding
statement if two of them are true pick
one non-deterministically if none of
them is true you're a
ball
okay the the do looks very similar but
has semantics that are in no way
parallel right well in some ways they're
parallel if if a guard is true you can
execute the
statement but then you go around and
execute the whole thing again there's an
implied repetition which doesn't come
from the keyword do and it doesn't come
from Loop but it's just you just have to
know it and the other thing that's
really odd is if there is no God that's
true we bought right just like if no you
skip if no God is true you do
nothing this is like an expanded while
condition do something
and Eric haa said well this is weird why
why don't we have consistent
defaults um and one of the things I
learned from this is if at least if
there are defaults you should make them
explicit so the syntax in three R was
instead of saying fire at the end here
we say otherwise
chaos right to make it clear that one of
those conditions better be true
otherwise bad things are going to
happen anyway um
the other idea that Eric he drew out of
D's papers is the paper is all about
program development by stepwise
refinement again and again through a
series of simple examples dyra says well
let's write a descriptive name for the
next thing we have to do you know make a
and b uh a less than b by while
maintaining some invariant right and
then he would write a piece of code that
does that which would use more named
chunks of code and then he would write
those and when you're done
you've got all these little bits of code
and you've got to paste them um uh back
together um I paste back together I mean
you know this was before we had
interactive editors you pasted them with
scissors and
glue and and Eric haa
said this is stupid computers are much
better at pasting text together than
than we are why don't we let the
computer do that and and the other thing
that Dy St is the reason he wrote the
book what's on the cover is I want to
explain the process by which I got to
these programs and he does that in his
text but the final program doesn't show
that process because all of these
refinements have disappeared so says
let's leave the names in the program so
the refinements are still visible oh and
once you've done that then you don't
need Loops at all because you can just
say oh you want to do that again we use
the name very simple idea so here's some
3r I was told um that Stranger loop is
supposed to be code heav
and I didn't actually have any code at
all but I'm not going to try and talk
about it you'll see there's otherwise
chaos there's a if condition if not same
inverse condition here's a let um and
there's a a block let that's called by
name and this is the definition of the
block with a wear Clause um and I don't
know it translates into for train
um so what did I learn from this
process a stupidly simple language can
solve real problems Brian sharing was
actually paying his bills with a version
of 3r right I mean he'd come up with a
language that was I'd refined it and
down the semantics and the formal syntax
and so forth but he'd actually been
writing code in this
language um the other thing I learned is
that you can't solve problems by
ignoring them the fact that sometimes
you can't finish is a real problem and
pretending that you always got to get to
the end and it's always going to be
successful doesn't help it right so
admit the problem exists then look for
Solutions don't try and brush it under
the
rug um let's fast forward a little bit
1982 I my first job as a assistant
professor at the University of
Washington and I'm working on the Eden
Project the Eden project was uh an early
attempt to build it it was probably the
earliest attempt to build an integrated
distributed computer system uh we had
three uh digital Equipment Corporation
vaxes connected together with networks
right using a version of Unix who didn't
even have networking right so we had to
add that so this is really early days
and um we devised this language called
the Eden programming
language it gave us synchronous object
invocation object invocations could be
local on the same machine or remote
across the network wonderful Innovative
idea gave us concurrent inside those
objects why do we need concurrency well
if you send a message across the network
what do you do You' got to sit there and
wait until something comes back right or
maybe you can do some other tasks so
there's concurrency comes into this and
no one had thought about that um we have
a way of addressing objects because this
is obor programming you need to talk
about objects so we had capabilities and
then we had a string package it seems
hard to remember standing here in 2023
that the used to be languages that
didn't have strings built in as a data
type but concurrent ukle didn't so we
added
something and here's some more code um I
don't really have time to go across
through this but the idea is that
there's a method request which looks
like you would expect root directory
some object dot method name right and
then there's some method body and the
program's expecting to write a method
body and a method call as some people
call it method
request but what's all this other stuff
well the good thing about eepl is that
it generated this crap and it generated
um and that sent the message across the
network which went to a little circle
which wasn't generated which then called
something called the call invocation
procedure which was generated which
eventually called the um the directory
code and then event sent the reply back
so all of this business that you have to
do in a Distributive system of packing
out parameters into packets setting
across the network
this circle was not generated because
you have to make some design decisions
okay there's a message coming in do I
have one process for each incoming
message do I have one process that takes
the messages and puts them in a queue do
I have a little poll of processes
there's a bunch of Alternatives you have
to choose from we didn't couldn't
automate that we didn't think we ought
to but we automated uh the messy work of
saying okay now you've got this packet
what procedure were you trying to call
what method name is in there what
parameters are in there unpack all of
that stuff call the right code so a lot
of the messy code was taken care
of um eppl I think was one of the
serendipitous successes of the Eden
project so Eden saw itself as
distributed systems research no one
other the project knew they needed a
programming language there's nothing in
the grant proposal that says we're going
to build a programming language but we
needed it because we had to write
programs so in hindsight EPO was
essential because it hid all this messy
stuff that I just talked about and free
programmers to focus on the interesting
and hard stuff like the algorithms for
replication for example and for
concurrency handling and so forth and
that was that was plenty to keep our
brains full so a little bit of language
which was just implemented by a fairly
thin simple pre-processor can go a long
way in making a system
usable 1983 887 87 was just after I left
the University of Washington but that's
sort of when the the students who were
involved uh Norm Hutchinson and Eric U
graduated so we've been doing this stuff
with the Eden project and the eppl but
we knew it wasn't very good I mean the
fact it worked at all was pretty amazing
um we didn't actually look like that by
the way these are the i e mic shots we
look kind of more like
this
uh uh and we all had our our backgrounds
I'd done work on my thesis and exception
handling uh which I I haven't talked
about um normal hyron working simul 67
um Eric had also used simul 67 and
concurrent Pascal and both of them had
taken a course on small talk but they
weren't Small Talk experts Hank ly came
from digital and had worked on
capability architectures his master's
thesis is a book on capability
architectures um so he had like the
systems
background and um the difference here
was we're now addressing building a
distributed system as a language problem
and we had this idea that we can have
three different implementations of
objects there were local objects remote
objects and direct
objects now this wasn't so stunning
right after all Eden already had two
implementations of objects we had
concurrent uid objects and we had Eden
objects which were Unix of Dr
spaces the thing about Emerald was we
said all three kinds of object are going
to have the same
semantics
this is true object encapsulation right
from the outside you can't tell what
kind of object you're looking at you
send the message in the same way and it
just
works so Dan Engles famous oops I just
turned it off uh Dan
Engles famously said in his paper on
Small Talk 7 76 small talk 2 one of the
early small talks
um it's clear that if you're going to
actually if you're going to send
messages for everything like plus three
on a non- message oriented computer
things are going to be too slow so you
have to
cheat and it's the implementor job to
cheat but not be
caught by which he set meant that the
user shouldn't be able to tell that
there's something weird going on under
the covers right even when you go down
into the debug everything should still
look like it's this virtual machine that
you've imagined of message
sending um so we came up with this idea
of location independent invocation um
and the compiled code was amazingly
efficient for for on object oriented
language of the time um it was in the
local case it was about as efficient as
C uh I say about because we had
concurrency so at the moment of every
Loop you had to check and see if some
other process wanted to but in right but
that was really the only difference in
the remote case it was a lot slower but
it was about 100 times faster than it
had been in Eden because instead of
calling all of these Li routines we
compiled
stuff and uh from that point of view it
was an amazing amazing success um so
from a language design point of view one
of the great Innovations I think is
object
Constructors and the idea of having
objects that are explicitly immutable
that is you declare them to be immutable
and why does that matter well in your
distributed system if you want things to
go fast you want things to happen
locally how do you make things happen
locally you replicate your objects if
you're replicating a mutable object well
then you need a consistency protocol
make sure that changes in one get
propagated changes in the other and it's
a big headache but if the object's
immutable you can replicate all you like
and no one can tell right so this is a
language designer distributive system
designer secret weapon immutable object
so we put those in the language we also
had a kind of failure handling because
once you've got a distributed system
failure is endemic right your machine is
up somebody else has crashed the network
is down you've got to handle failure and
we had parameterized types
well because we wanted the language to
be
small which meant that things like sets
and
arrays wouldn't be built in there'll be
libraries well if you have a set Library
you need to be able to say is this a set
of integers or is it a set of students
or is it a set of directories right so
parameterized types fell out of that
then we spent the next 10 or 15 years
trying to do the type Theory there's
still open issues there um but in other
ways it was really very conventional
right we had conventional words we have
objects with processes just not very
like similar co- routines we had hore
monitors not Mesa monitors but hor
monitors for synchronization um and we
made some simplifications because hey
this was two graduate students and two
professors kitsy so no classes no
inheritance on reflection AMR was about
20 years before its time
right um we sent uh proposals to the
National Science Foundation reviewers
sent them back saying you can't possibly
implement this so we implemented it
anyway um and then they gave us some
money by which time I'd left the
university um it's still generating
dissertations currently there were some
hard issues like distributed garbage
collection in the presence of failure
that um are still PhD
worthy the original paper that we sent
to sosp almost wasn't published uh this
is one of the referees reports we got um
f growing mobility in the emerald system
referees report this is a
straightforward implementation of a
simple idea it's hard to see what is
unique about this operating system
period um curiously um this is still my
most influential paper if
you if you count
citations um there are other papers on
Emerald there's one called Emerald a
general purpose program language which
from a language point of view might be
more interesting that came later but
this is the one that's mostly
cited so emal was not widely used um
there were some generations of students
from arus and uh uh University of Oslo
who have been forced to use it in Eric's
distri systems class um and they really
like it U but it's not ever been widely
used um but it has been widely
influential
um another thing that's interesting here
is that we were acting as our own
customers programmed in Eden we knew
what the problems we were that that
system had we were trying to solve them
um it's quite as a lot easier to design
a language for yourself because you know
when you've succeeded right you know
what your goal is you don't have to keep
on checking with your
customer um and it freed us to think
about the hard problems the hard
problems in distributive system are
where you put the objects and
concurrency control not they shouldn't
be how you communicate with them
all right how am I doing for time I have
a watch I've always already run out of
time I
think I I've got five
minutes all right I'm going to I'll run
late I'm apparently I'm already
overlapping with the talks on either end
so um I'll keep on going and if you
drift out because you need lunch I'll
understand so traits um was
um another collaborative effort it's a
language feature not a language um It's
a Small Talk class a trait is a small
talk class that doesn't have instance
variables um and the point about traits
is you can combine them there's an
algebra you can combine them with plus
you can modify them with u method
aliasing and exclusion and you can then
use them in other traits so this is sort
of the canonical diagram this shows how
you can do in ordinary
inheritance um using a trait
and the clever idea that Nathaniel shley
came up with this all happened in burn
when I was on sabatical when it's really
old Jud and Nathaniel uh was that if
there's anything that you don't like
there's a method you don't like that
You' otherwise inherit uh you can fix it
in the gluc code you're inheriting from
two places um and you want something
from here and something from there the
gluc code can specify what goes on you
don't have to go back to the
manufacturer or the writer of some
library and say you have to fix that for
me
and then there's this idea of an algebra
of traits where conflicts are persistent
so if you have a c method here and a c
method there and you combine them you
get a conflict and it stays around until
you explicitly resolve it it doesn't
just disappear because then if you added
in a third trait um the conflict would
be it could might be replaced by some
other object and now you've magically
resolved it so most of the problems with
multiple inheritance come back from
automatic
uh conflict
resolution Steve Cook famously wrote
channeling Alan Schneider multiple
inheritance is good but there's no good
way to do it right and I think this is a
good way to do it because it again gets
rid of the default so makes everything
clear on the surface and gives you the
power to fix things that need to be
fixed so this came out of deep
experience with small talk I was working
in the small talk group in the
University of burn um Nathaniel who
worked in Alan K's lab knew a lot more
about small talk and he came up with
this great idea he says if we leave out
the instance
variables then we don't have to worry
about the diamond
problem and it's like why didn't anyone
think of that
before right so that's what we did uh a
little Lattis theory that let these
persistent conflicts hang around uh came
from my background at Oxford and um the
excellent toour building environment
that small T gave us and Nathaniel's
programming skills meant you could put
this whole thing together uh with really
nice Tools in a few months right so we
uh we sent uh in many ways this is the
smallest contribution it's just a little
language feature but it might have had
more impact than anything else I've done
um it actually the eou paper describing
this won the test of time award at e
coup this summer and I gave a version of
this talk which has none the stuff at
the beginning but more of the stuff at
the end that you're probably going to
miss so uh you know if you're interested
you can go listen to that one it's it's
uh on the website um the other thing
that we got wrong or the one thing we
got wrong is we underestimated the
importance of programming tools so there
are claims that went in this paper um
like there's no penalty for um
decomposing your classes into really
small traits that you can reuse in many
ways and execution wise there's no
penalty but what we meant was in human
cognition there's no penalty and the
reason there was no penalty is Nathaniel
had built this wonderful browser that
let you look at the system at different
levels so you could see everything
brought together you could go up and
down the traits hierarchy you could
navigate and see where the things came
from and that was really great but if
you don't have that then indeed there is
a penalty because if you have you know
19 different you know dot Java files and
you've got to try and look at them all
to see where things are coming from it's
not so
easy so
um I mentioned Simplicity earlier that
one of my goals was to be as uh simple
as possible as Sony uh said so did
traits simplify the small talk language
and the answer is no they made it
significantly more complicated because
we already had inheritance and now we
had these traits and combination rules
and overriding and so forth
but what they did was they removed
complexity redundancy and misleading
structure from the small talk
system the overall programming system
was simpler even though the language was
now a little bit more
complicated um traits would be simpler
if we took out something like method
exclusion you don't need method
exclusion you could just rewrite the
trait without the method you don't want
right and then put that in another trait
and then recompose things but that's a
pain in the neck and a big overhead and
means you need access to the
source so programming with rates would
be harder and it's the programming
process we want to be simple not just
the language so my recommended reading
for this is not actually the eou paper
though I'm sure it's very very good um
it's the paper that eou
rejected on their right to do so because
it was a bit premature that went to
upser the same year and this describes
the process of applying traits to a
fairly complicated uh inheritance
hierarchy in small talk the collections
hierarchy and how we actually simplified
it we got rid of a lot of extra code um
and made it more
understandable well
um yeah so this is uh I like dick
Gabriel so I'll put in one more paper I
love uh because I like the way dick
writes uh but this paper amongst other
things talks about this dichotomy
between language and system we used to
talk about programming systems now we
tend to talk about programming languages
that's only part of the equation so let
me go to my
um uh my
summary because I've taken far too much
of your time how do I do this uh I want
to
go isn't there a
go-to there was a go-to number
somewhere which I figured it out before
slide number here we are open oh I just
typed 75 okay does that
work no okay here here's the summary
slide so there's languages in gray that
I haven't uh talked about
um Grace and Fortress being amongst them
the languages in green are the other
languages I've not been involved in but
have influenced my thinking and the
arrows represent influence right so SM
influence Grace with message names bcpl
influence 3r by having square brackets
for
uh procedure parameters uh traits went
into Java Java influence Fortress and so
on uh your homework is to put labels on
all of the
arrows um I want to conclude with a
thought on why programming language
design is hard and I think it's hard
because a programming language is not
just or even primarily a means for
programmers to communicate with
computers it's also a means for progr
programmers other programmers and
themselves programmers programming
languages are a tool of thought and a
good programming language is a social as
well as a technical
enabler and it's because a language has
to serve this Dual Purpose that um it
makes it hard to design and also because
it's a social phenomenon it makes
language adoption slow like any social
change but there is this sort of H
hundredth monkey effect that no one is
using uh python for example for the
first 20 years and then suddenly
everyone is using python wow why were
you why are you teaching with python
well everyone's using
python so um maybe uh you haven't maybe
in another 20 years people will start
using
grace and the final thought is all
designs are influenced by what's in the
designer's heads um and I've tried to
give you a little sampling of what was
in my head in the last 40 plus
years um I keep coming back because I
like fixing things there's plenty to fix
in programming so um that's why we
wanted more good students and they also
like helping others to succeed and a
good language will help the programmers
uh to do a better
job so here's my reading list this is
supposed to be papers we love um some of
the I mentioned notation as a tool of
thought and that of course is the title
of Ken Iverson's uh uh touring award I
believe um and I'll leave that list up
here there's also a list of uh of
references um on the next slide but I'm
assuming the slides can be made
available
and um that's the
end hi Andrew um what you were saying
about traits as a tool and
simplification really resonated uh last
couple years I've made this jump from
like Java stuff to rust stuff um I was
wondering what you thought about effect
systems and how those work with language
like effect systems like coca and stuff
like that as what how do what do you
think about those as like a new tool for
expression well yes so I have thought
about effect systems um and that was
actually something that came out of my
my experience with
Fortress um Fortress had a very strong
type system that told you exactly what
data went in what data went out but it
said nothing about
effects and this was a concurrent
language so whether or not there effects
was really important and it's like why
doesn't the type system capture that um
so I studied effect systems a little bit
decided um it was more complicated than
I could wrap my brain around um but you
know smarter people have worked on this
so we can argue that monads are an
effect system um they're sort of a
equivalent but take come to the problem
from a different direction um and so I
looked at that a little bit with f
watler but I never have never published
anything or made any real progress so
open open area for you thank
you uh again when you're were discussing
uh traits as a language feature you had
mentioned tooling support and it really
really resonated with me uh lately over
the past couple years we've seen tools
like Tre sitter and language servers
that have really raised the bar for what
we expect of new programming languages
and how they enter up with the other
tooling that we use how do you recommend
that new language designers balance
these new expectations that we have for
what tools need what languages and what
tools need to do with the new features
and new Sant that they're actually
exploring with their designs I know I've
fallen into the Trap of just exclusively
building tooling and losing trap or TR
I'm not catching everything you're
saying there's too much background noise
but you're asking about a language Des
know realizing you need tool support for
the language to be successful and how do
you balance that with actually exploring
what it is that you're trying to
contribute to to programming language
design I
guess um since you can build tooling
forever and then you can build tooling
forever when do you stop you can keep on
adding language features forever when do
you stop right have you ever found a way
to balance that
well I mean you don't have to the the
good thing about tooling is it doesn't
change the program that's already
running so the trouble with changing a
language is you can never take a feature
out because you're going to break all
the programs that exist or it's very
hard I mean C++ has tried to pull things
back but it's a it's a decades long
process but tools aren't like that um
you build a system and if people find
they need a tool they can add a tool to
do something and if no one uses it it
will wither away and if it's lots of
people use it then it will get enhanced
and more people people will use it and
it becomes more useful so I don't really
think there's a conflict there you just
need a large enough team I the problem
with Grace is there's three of us and I
was the only one writing code and there
were some students you know they'll work
for a quarter on a project and then
they'll go away and I had to maintain it
so we didn't get to build much in the
way of tooling um the fact that we
actually have a programming environment
that's usable to teach a class of 100
plus novices and it runs on the web you
so you can run it on your IP ad or to me
is actually pretty amazing but that's
because you know there's all those
engineers at uh at Google who made V8
right so you can turn out incredibly
crappy JavaScript and it'll run Lally
split right so um we didn't have to
worry too much about uh speed and that
helps a lot okay thank
you thank you Andrew thank you so much
hi um earlier you had a slide with some
recommendations and I was wondering from
your experience teaching students um if
it's been more effective to explore the
different paradigms with different
languages or um taking a course like
ablon and susman where they use scheme
to explore logic functional
object-oriented concurrent programming
if if you found a difference in
Effectiveness with one language versus
multiple I haven't try the able
assessment
approach you should be aware that the
last 16 years of my career I was
teaching at Porton State University
which you know is is like the last best
chance University in in Oregon is where
students go who didn't go to the the big
name uh state colleges University of
Oregon Oregon State um there people who
and they're not MIT students right we
get some really good students but we
also get some really mediocre students
so um
trying to teach somewhere in the middle
of that group and I think if you have a
language
that you know if you want to teach
functional programming it's much easier
to do it in a language like high school
than it is in a language like scholar or
uh lisp where you have all these other
paradigms available because you don't
you the instructor don't have to do so
much channeling right you just let them
take the path of least resistance and
they'll come up with the right program
one of the great ideas in Grace which we
stole from um from Brown Shri and Christ
mury and the his his teaching projects
is this idea of uh dialects so I can
write as an instructor a dialect that
adds methods and libraries but also runs
checks over the students
code and if if the compiler tells them
the indentation wrong or you didn't
write write a purpose statement in that
method or the purpose statement doesn't
say anything about the third
parameter then they fix it I don't have
to do anything right they feel better
because I haven't criticized them and I
have more time to actually deal with the
real problems so I think a language that
constrains what you do uh can actually
be really valuable now if your students
are really smart yeah you can you can
program o in Assembly
Language thank
you